[Music]
for the first time a socialite charged
with killing a police superintendent in
belize is telling her story in detail
jasmine harden is accused of shooting
and killing henry jamat last may the
case made international headlines she
claims it was an accident but his family
says it was murder in an exclusive tv
interview hardin told her story to 48
hours correspondent peter van sam
i was frantic running up and down the
pier just after midnight on may 28th
authorities detained jasmine harton
after finding the 32 year old mother of
twins dazed and blood soaked on a pier
near the five-bedroom beachfront condo
she shared with her partner andrew
ashcroft son of a british billionaire 42
year old superintendent of police henry
jamaat is dead in the water belize
police superintendent henry jamaat a
fatal gunshot wound behind his right ear
his sister cherry says he was a man
beloved by his five children and his
country he had done a great job for the
country of belize
two people wind up
on a lonely pier in the dark together
why are they there
belize channel 7 reporter and cbs
consultant charisse hausau the first
thing jasmine harten said was that a
passing boat shot henry jeff after
meeting with a lawyer harton's story
reportedly changed
i don't remember
saying that you know and i think i was
in shock
were you intentionally trying to mislead
police at that moment no
harton was charged with negligent
manslaughter she says she and jamat were
drinking before they went to the pier
where he tried to show her how to load
and unload his glock 17 for her own
protection i'm trying to click out the
magazine next thing i know the gun went
off my brother was shot
behind the air execution style
cherry jamaat doesn't buy jasmine's
story and she's not just henry's sister
she's also a cop jasmine hardin should
be charged for murder
and not manslaughter you have admitted
shooting and killing henry jamaat was it
an accident
or was it murder
it was absolutely not murder henry was
my friend
peter vincent joins us now good morning
eater so henry's family they believe it
was murder absolutely why well first off
henry's sister cherry is a police
officer on the island and she and the
family just don't buy jasmine's story
because it reportedly changed from him
being shot from somebody in a passing
boat to an accidental shooting so
they're very suspicious about that and
they say well if it was an accidental
shooting
how was he shot behind his right ear
which they considered to be execution
style it's something we get into very
deeply during my interview with jasmine
about all of those circumstances who
says
that she was giving him a massage in the
moments prior to
this
gun going on so rare to see you actually
sit down with the killer and the
conversations about accident or not as
opposed to who it is that pulled the
trigger so what's next for jasmine
harden well we're waiting for the trial
date to be set right now she has to
report every day to a a court there is a
custody fight going on with her children
because her partner in life andrew
ashcroft is the son of lord michael
ashcroft a multi-billionaire who is a
very powerful person in belize he owns
the port in the phone system in a number
of the banks
so this is a huge story down there and
journalists from four countries had been
trying to get to jasmine and we got
there first you did
you're daring
thank you we appreciate it looking
forward to it now you can see peter's
report jasmine harden's shot in the dark
on 48 hours tomorrow at 10 9 central
here on cbs and on the viacom cbs
streaming service paramount plus